so here is a penis and here is the
precone did you guys learn all this in
your sex ed hi my name is Daniela I'm
Shelby hi my name is Nadia hi my name is
Emily and we're throwing it back to high
school today cuz we're taking a sex ed
quick I think sex is something a lot of
people are ashamed about it's pretty
taboo topic but you know it's everywhere
and we should we all need to brush up on
our sex ed think I had a really good sex
education in high school and I will tell
you all what I was told which is that
sex is neither good nor bad it is
powerful oh and you have to be
responsible
oh great we are
I thought it was gonna be general stuff
I thought it was gonna be a lot about
like the fallopian tubes
yeah that's unlikely false advertising
there dude rude we got it don't i'm
penis expert it's fine
Oh a sexist women I don't question one
read it
what are doctors who specialize in the
health care of male sexual and
reproductive organs called we have
neurologists obstetrics and gynecology I
am that's us and the technologist that's
glans Rheumatologist oh it's urologist
all right neurologist terms of like
penis health and stuff like that
urologist okay loos only few know what
you're talking about so we're gonna go
with I'm 80% sure yeah neurologist true
or false people with penises get yeast
infections okay I know for a fact that
that is true and I know that like aside
from getting a yeast infection on your
genitals you can also get east
infections and other parts of your body
thinking it I think they can get in the
nooks infections but like just in a
different way yeah I mean cuz it's
usit's candida right I mean what is the
average length of an erect penis
okay the inches 4 inches 5 inches or 7
inches 5
okay um you know I think right I don't
know I do not want to give them that
much crap okay
sevens being a little generous this is
I'm pretty sure okay and like yeah I
don't think it's that I think that's - I
think it's too long
be a happy medium would be five inches
you know why it's like I'm thinking even
larger so what y'all think I'll go with
either four or five let's go with four
cuz now I'm not confident anymore so
forth we're gonna for four inches people
how far can penises shoot sperm also
would like to reiterate this question
says shoot sperm we have six inches one
foot two feet and five feet one foots
about this so much I mean which I've
experienced oh my god hmm this is
disturbing okay
honestly I might make them depending on
how long it's been
early you know the sexual frustration
yeah I mean like there could be a lot of
pressure in there it's you know why
so let's also think about like how far
needs to shoot to get a woman pregnant
for the swim
I think I think two feet maybe no I
think five innings five that's it I knew
I answer with whale I'm going I think
one whale penis is what's that well what
is that well I know that like they
should sperm at it like apparently it's
like as at the rate and the speed of
like a gunshot
like the vagon bullets going on it like
so it's like really fast although maybe
it's kinda like when you sneeze that can
go like charity peacefully from a whale
ejaculation that's justified
funny that's gonna financier it is you
just might want to get out of the line
of fire with that one don't comes Leon
does the speed change in the water
versus outside that's a good question
and this is something we can investigate
let's do one theory speculates that the
motion of a penis thrust inside a vagina
evolved from a reflex intended to blank
a sexually satisfy the partner II ensure
proper semen transferal see a protective
technique during cold weather vendee
remove the sperm of other competitors
whoa sexually satisfy the partner
definitely not like first and foremost
is evolutionary yes of course and that
in itself is evolution yeah at its
finest it's certainly okay so I think we
can get rid of sexually satisfy the
partner and also get rid of a protective
technique drink oh no that would be
actually really funny if that was
actually true so I can go with ensure
proper semen transfer all oh I'm sure
I'm sure the perhaps okay dryerballs
penis size correlates to a person's foot
size balls boss balls all I Falls but
what if they're tricking us cuz that's
like the most you know what I mean but
that's what no a penny a penny did Amal
hypertension is the medical term for
which colloquial phrase masturbation wet
dreams blue balls
premature ejaculation hypertension
that's the you know earlier today she
was saying that blue balls this is a
mouth and you know I kind of believe her
but now I'm just feeling like yeah
hypertension part seems to go with with
blue balls epididymal so skin fish balls
hypertension it's cold blue balls could
be let's hope we're wrong let's hope her
I don't want it to be blue balls but
Morgana's we're gonna say blue balls
attention it's blue balls blue balls is
like a myth too but it says cool cool I
don't think it's a myth I just
they put it on women when like he's a
man like essentially don't have sex like
oh my balls are because they're ready to
we literally push humans out of our you
can deal with not go to the bathroom
true or false
a penis can get stuck into the drain Oh
balls crew maybe that's true that is so
damn true if it's gonna get stuck in a
vagina
I can't even like it it won't even get
in there in the first place I know that
vaginas can stretch like it's and then
maybe if it like something happened
because I know what his baby can come
out of there you what you wish your
penis could get stuck I feel like
there's no medical cases yeah I feel as
though you know it's not the woman's
like nervous and my clamps down
something yeah and then also you know
this isn't even including the
possibility of like I dick piercing
getting stuck in there like god I don't
freaking know anything can happen
so yeah that's nightmare fuel really
what is the earliest time penises can
experience an erection as a toddler
during puberty in the womb six months
after birth damn this is this is dark
this is interesting I've talked to many
a male friends an erection is different
than ejaculation absolutely so like I
think they're like penis can feel like
good great but like nothing will come
out until like 10 12 yeah I like how
you've talked to many men about this I'm
gonna say dude what every six months
after birth is an option to Utah yeah
I'm either as a toddler and then one no
I think I've been toddler maybe it's I
think it's a toddler because it doesn't
mean because it's like they can't like
actually Ling an ejaculation but I think
they can get yeah I think it is it might
be as a toddler yeah so we're gonna
unfortunately as a toddler it's wild if
it's in the room I'm gonna freak out I
may be shook
here you go next one true or false you
can get pregnant from pre-cut that is
Prewitt rooms are the first things that
they taught us in a sex ed yeah
obviously as a tactic take hello is not
the method no please just condoms and
birth control sperm can survive in the
uterus for up to blank days we've got
two five seven we've got fourteen I
don't think it's it's either 7 or 14 a
week sounds like decent to me seven days
do you think it's too because it's like
you can't take Plan B like Plan B is
only effective 7 days is when a lot of
miracles have happened historically
yeah like when the the ring with girl
comes back - right like that one
specific I think it's fine I remember it
being like kind of a crazy number we're
gonna go five days five days
well the sevens fine whatever we'll take
the L for that one potentially firm is
produced in the penis testicles prostate
perineum testicles it has to the
testicles actually but just want to
question myself for a second like that's
where it's stored not perennial
testicles yeah
the balls oh is it produced Oh testicles
Oh Susie the perineum their pit I know
perineum is the piece of skin in between
your butthole I've got something else
no the what like men have a prostate but
we don't but and I don't really know
what the function is all I know is it
makes it hard for old men to pee I still
think it's the testicles no let's do
tests for EMU testicles we're doing
testicles do you think it's testicles
are prostate the prostate
no that's their g-spot I'm gonna I'm
gonna default to you all right if I'm
wrong I'll buy you a sequel write me a
doughnut I'll scream Gooch in public
what fills the penis during interaction
that makes it hard okay we got lied seam
in water or testosterone blood semen no
just getting its blood okay what do you
think I know what it is what yeah
oh we're done we're done feeling
confident we're feeling good we're
feeling sex educated we are feeling sex
educated well we could answered all of
these questions so now I guess we will
see how we did
we'll see if Emily's a penis expert the
jury is Adam the jury is out on that
it's been a while
what are doctors who specialize in the
health care of male sexual and
reproductive organs calls we answered
your ologist hell yeah people with
penises can get yeast infections and we
only thought we said Charles refer you
to what is the average length of an
erect penis we did it ultimately end up
going with four oh one inch difference
though yeah I guess that is quiet yes
that does make a difference
penis pros how far can penises shoot
[Music]
sled you okay Oh
[Music]
one theory speculates that the motion of
a penis thrusts inside a vagina evolved
from a reflex intended to ensure proper
Steven transferral we said ensure proper
semen transferral I get it yeah that
evolutionarily sounds correct yes that's
insane penis science correlates with a
person's foot size when we said it's all
false epididymal hypertension is the
medical term for which colloquial phrase
I know it's real okay
balls are gonna explode got it okay so
it's not a health crisis true or false
a penis can get stuck in a vagina and
that's true that is fully true yeah a
penis can get stuck in how do you like
your like okay we'll just put a blank
just like walk to the hospital what is
the earliest time penises can experience
an erection and we said as a toddler I
said one to two to the two too high
true or false you can get pregnant from
pre-cum what whoa what okay so if
there's leftovers fresh jack whoa Aaron
can survive in the uterus for up to how
many days a week we said seven days we
went with five that's right that's trick
firm is produced in the we said
testicles that would have been
embarrassing if I said prostate prostate
I don't think I can call myself the
penis Pro anymore I've lost it there
were no questions about that difference
in here those are my specialty
what fills the penis during erection
that makes it hard we said what we said
what we did yes so indeed I know but
it's like about 50 right it's not enough
I think we did pretty good considering
how long it's been since we've been in
high school I just answer class and be
like listen I don't know what happened
this is another fair example of my
knowledge you know do I know the deep
good one good one Shelby I hate my
father
stay safe kids the the sperm shooting if
there wasn't like a like like in what's
the word uterus and like cervix and then
the rest of your body like that would
literally like there's also another way
can get in your throat
yeah
[Music]